I'm looking over there and being
distracted because Dale Earnhardt jr.
just came in so uh Jr come on over he's
stuck in traffic come on in my bud
you're all sweaty here you have you been
running okay all right what's good to
see you you too
thanks yeah it's good to be here so you
got stuck in traffic yeah there's a
little tougher than than usual for some
reason but you weren't driving no I
wasn't you don't drive in New York we
yeah I don't really I don't know my way
around but usually we have you know we
understand kind of the time that you
need you have to have a little extra
time and never plan on getting here
about thirty minutes early but it didn't
work out so yeah I don't know what's
going on this week but it's a little
slower than usual well we're glad to
have you you look good you look like
you're in shape do you work out you know
that's a no all right
Jimmie Johnson got me in cycling about a
year and a half two years ago so last
year I rode 2,400 miles and you know
probably not riding as much this year
due to having the baby and and all that
but I like the ride do you do spin
classes and I did it up once or twice
but mainly just when there's a charity
one yeah town there's the girls you know
the group the wives and girlfriends of
the other drivers put those together for
charity and so forth and we may go do
that but those are harder than riding on
the road spin classes because they keep
you held you accountable in that spin
class man yeah on the road you know you
trying to do your thing but you got
other people watching you and this man
did that too it gets real competitive I
was in spin yesterday how was it it was
great the entire all the music was David
Bowie oh that's pretty good it was
awesome
the music's key in all in class and you
get a bad bad DJ in there it's not good
what kind of music would you have a hard
time pedaling - Oh probably some slow
R&B stuff like that you know just what
would you love to hear David Bowie would
be great and you know what there's a
rhythm acadians to when you're riding
right and that's what they're trying to
get the one part I don't like too about
the spin class is the bar the arm
thing I didn't know they had the art I
didn't know they you know worked your
arms while you're in there and so
they're there like grab this bar and
you're holding it straight out and and
I'm like you know this is not very
comfortable
do you have a garter the type bike
shorts on yeah yeah I have to wear this
yeah you know spandex is part of cycling
unfortunately and so Jimmy Johnson is
the one who got you yeah Jimmy got me
ridin a lot of drivers ride bikes on
Friday there's the first early morning
practice before lunch and then we'll
have qualifying at like 4:00 or 5:00 and
afternoon so there's a big gap of time
and there's a loop or you know 30 or 20
mile loop sorry is that your phone
that's my text alert yeah oh my god
screaming is that a rooster no it was a
guy going woohoo did you have a special
one when your wife checks you I don't
think so oh they all sound asleep
yeah yeah so sorry professional yeah
you're a broadcaster now I wouldn't
expect you to have that that sound
effect Rotex well it sort of cheers me
up no matter what the taste is even if
it's bad news
does your wire in there with a good good
good attention but if your wife calls
you does does her ring is it different
have you differentiating you don't do
that yeah I never have my ring on so I
don't know why my sound Mazzone cuz I
don't even have my vibrating on silent
turned on did you ever have a phone in
the car with you when you drive all the
time I mean they told us probably way
back about way back but forty four or
five years ago Brad Keselowski got in
trouble for taking a picture during a
red flag out of his windshield and
during when Juan Pablo wrecked into the
the jet dryer at Daytona Brack his last
take a picture of it from the inside of
his race car NASCAR said well you know
it's a bad deal we can't have electronic
devices in the cars so no more phones
but I had a pocket in my suit on my leg
and I would put my phone
in there and you know I just had to be
careful if I had any car camera about
pulling it out cuz I'd I mean there
texting and carrying on in between you
know practices or whatever you know I
didn't use it for any kind of advantage
oh is that what they were worried about
you could take it and find a way to
create an app or some device or control
something in the car that might trick
something up or give you an advantage
and so or record you know you could just
record data from the engine or whatever
but you never like during a caution you
never didn't care about that I was just
trying to keep up with Twitter and you
know text message from friends and I you
know I can't imagine you imagined your
dad on Twitter like no yeah that texting
yeah he he hated computers when I was
trying to get my first computer he was
like I don't know why you're doing that
to waste your time wasting time
why are you doing that and you know it
was it was he thought it was completely
ridiculous to have a computer didn't
think it was going to amount to have a
home computer we'll take a break here
Dale jr. is joining us on behalf talk
about his new book it's racing to the
finish my story and we'll come back
we'll talk to him about that
and is a broadcasting career the new
baby all those good things will continue
with Dale jr. right after this the book
is racing to the finish my story
reflection on jr. the concussions that
he had and it's a topic that we've
addressed a couple of times with him
talks about the slow recovery admiration
for his wife Amy who stood by him
through all of this and shares his
experience you can catch Dale this
Sunday 2:00 Eastern when NBC SN presents
the Monster Energy NASCAR Cup Series
playoff and they'll be Dover
International Speedway what what would
surprise us in this book well the it's
hard to tell without ruining the book
but I know how it is I you know there's
a there's throughout my throughout 2013
14 15 and in - 16
a lot of things going on that I didn't
tell anybody about I hid a lot of stuff
from the racing world my wife everybody
and it caught up with me and the the
reason why I missed half a season was
because of that misstep and misjudgment
and poor decision-making why were you
hiding because I thought that if I was
good enough or felt good enough by you
know if I crashed on Sunday and I and I
and I felt good Wednesday or Thursday
then I was fine to go race again and so
I did that repeatedly and didn't realize
that my brain was still wounded still
hurting still needing to be you know
still needing to time to heal and how do
you hide that you I so the the way we
wrote the book is is throughout from
2012 all the way up till I got well in
2016
I took a diary I wrote a diary of notes
every time I crashed and got sick or
felt bad I wrote down notes about it for
the whole week
you know Monday morning Monday at lunch
Monday night Tuesday morning every day I
was writing notes about how I felt
because when I would if you know if I if
I got well or started feeling better on
Thursday I couldn't remember what I felt
like on Monday and so the notes would
help me understand how far I was getting
you know getting how I was getting well
and how much better I felt and so and I
was just scared to I was really scared
so I was writing these notes and just
just have some kind of memory of what I
was going through and when I got hurt
and started when I got so bad that I
couldn't drive anymore and I knew that I
needed to get out of the race car I took
those notes to my doctor and he was
really angry with me this is the same
doctor Mikki Collins did I saw in 2012
and so obviously my wife when she found
out she was extremely upset and people
have read the book say the same thing
they are like man I really want to want
to punch you in the face and then I want
to give you a hug so but there's also
this mentality of you're a NASCAR driver
you're tough guy
ya know I got I'm supposed to is this
part of what everybody does
yeah but I'm I was at the I was at the
back side of my career had nothing to
gain from continuing to you know trudge
through those kind of issues had had
accomplished what I wanted to accomplish
and had saved my money was well off
financially and and had business
opportunities in a future and a wife and
a family and all this stuff on my on the
horizon you know and and there was no
point in me in taking that kind of risk
now if I was 25 years old and just
getting into the sport and trying to
make my name and trying to establish
myself and afraid of losing my ride to
someone really easily I would have you
know that would have that would have
probably been some excuse if there is an
excuse to do something like that but I
had no excuse for doing that I already
knew enough about concussions from the
2012 experience of going through it that
this was a bad choice and I made it
anyways and the whole time I'm out there
telling people this is what not to do
and I met and I'm actually doing you so
I couldn't come clean as a driver when I
was still racing in my final season 2012
17 I didn't want to tell this story
because I didn't want my final year that
I'm you know kind of closing my career
out to be about concussions and types
and you know this this the secret that
I'd kept so as soon as I was out of the
car and retired I thought I'd it's time
to write the book I want to write the
book the whole purpose of writing this
book is to help my my doctor Mikki
Collins Oh Mickey Collins gave me my
life back
anybody that's went to Mickey and got
help and got well knows exactly what
that means and I feel in debt to Mickey
to support him and raise awareness for
United
it's Berg Medical Center and what they
do there to help people with head
injuries and so this he is also kind of
intertwined in the the the contents of
the book sort of backing up a lot of the
things that we went through and in
describing in medical terms about what
I'm feeling and doing and all those
things and how we went through the rehab
and so forth so I him being involved in
the book as well as a lot of credibility
to it so I want people to read it and
it's a good picture here yeah thanks
yeah I want people to read it and and
hopefully it'll educate the people and
help some people so a final minute here
helps how's the baby oh I was awesome
doing something new every day
she's just five months old and starting
to you know she's she's just doing
something new every single day and you
don't want to leave home I don't and you
know I'm gonna fly I need to be in Dover
tonight but I'm gonna fly home and when
I leave New York and be with them for
about an hour go back to Dover so I mean
that's when your dad you understand what
that is like if you get a moment you got
to be there and I'm gonna be going all
weekend and that's good so I need to get
as you know when you can be there you
need to be there racing to the finish my
story Dale Earnhardt jr. you look like a
movie star I appreciate how many I'm not
getting any rolls though you're calling
the phone's not have you been in any
movies no I mean as myself like in the
Will Ferrell movie Talladega Talladega
but yeah Adam Sandler is watching right
now in fact he's text a little bit at
school okay you met Adam before he
actually asked me I met him in Hawaii
and he was flying in and I was leaving
and he asked me to take his dog home are
you telling me that I never met the guy
interesting story the book is racing to
the finish my story with Dale Earnhardt
jr. great to see you jr. thanks for
joining us for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct
TV or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]